welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul and valentine's day
is cancelled because the new justice
league snyder cut trailer
is finally here me and the wife had a
lovely day yesterday
because i told her after a leap year
that valentine's day happens on the 13th
but it's over now and we're here to
bring you all the granny goodness on the
new look as well as what the extra and
additional shots could be
you're living in a [ __ ] dream world
if you think there won't be spoilers
here
and as we will be talking about aspects
of the nightmare scenes
you might want to switch off if not and
you enjoy the video then please hit the
thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe as we're
almost at the half a million mark and
you can tell people you knew me before
it was cool
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so up top i think one thing that we
have to address is that the movie is
officially orated
and in the words of jonathan kent [ __ ]
them kids
i know there's been some backlash to
this but i honestly can't think of the
last time that i actually
checked what the writing of a movie was
before watching it the main controversy
surrounding this is how it's not really
suitable for kids
but i also don't know any kids who are
willing to sit through a 4-hour film
i think a big change in the comic book
industry came in the 80s when companies
realized that
adults actually spent more money on
comic book stuff than kids did
and no mom it's not a toy it's a 400
action figure that must be kept in its
box at all times
there's a lot of money to make out of us
adults and therefore
marketing things within our rating
doesn't mean that they won't be
successful
snyder has been given full creative
control over the project
and it's clear that he's making the
movie he wants to make so if you just
want a fun and friendly version of the
film
then guess what you've got justice
league
pain now if you were following the
comments on the last trailer then you'll
know that a lot of people drew the
conclusion
that it would pretty much be the exact
same movie with just a couple of extra
scenes
i think with this trailer they really
pushed this idea to the side and did
include some focus on dark side
and characters that weren't in the
original from the off i'll say that i
think they
absolutely nailed this is the way to
promote the movie and i would much
rather watch this 500 times
than watch the joss whedon version
anymore
ever again anyway we kick start with
superman's death in batman v superman
and his super cries completely rocked
the landscape
shaking it and also ringing the bell for
dark side and steppenwolf
in the original trailer there was a line
about how there were no lanterns or
kryptonians
and after the first invasion failed they
were clearly biding their time until
earth's protectors had fallen
and the ringing of this bell in many
ways symbolizes that now's the time to
strike
now some behind the scenes stuff a
family feud as it were
after the first invasion of earth failed
darkseid cast stepping wolf out and
this is very much him trying to win back
favor with his
lovely lovely nephew so when i say ring
the bell for dark side and steppenwolf
what i really mean is the former who's
then gonna offer up the planet as a
present
just keep me alive i've got puns i am
with something i swear
now from here we go to the mascara and
see hippolyta staring over into the
ocean
this might be one of the cliffs that her
daughter dived off decades before
that could also be a reach we then see
the tomb where the mother box was held
being pushed off a cliff i'm guessing
that this is after the attack by
steppenwolf
and they're now just closing everything
off because they've realized that hope
may be lost
and it's pointless keeping it around cut
to the nightmare timeline
and we see what i believe is batman
going to get the joker
at the end of the trailer the two meet
and this definitely seems like it's
tying in with that moment
the trailer actually contains several
points from the nightmare timeline
that we did see parts of in batman v
superman there are rumors that this is
actually how the movie ends
and according to the leaks the film will
tease to us that the league were unable
to stop the latter invasion by darkseid
and after lois was killed superman ended
up succumbing to his power
and he too fell in line this is of
course what we saw in batman v superman
and from what we know about the joker
deathstroke and mira's role in the
reshoots
it looks like they're all teaming up to
take him down you also know from bvs
that the flash travels backwards in time
so there is potential that this is set
up here which brings everything full
circle
darkseid's legion has taken over the
planet and it turns out that the joker
actually managed to get his hands on
them of the box
batman then goes to him with cyborg and
deathstroke and he has to work with his
arch enemy for the greater good
he says we live in a society which i
think might be a little nod to phoenix's
portrayal
but that's been meme to death so i'm not
sure either way if it is
the lad's still hilarious he's still got
it and he's my favorite hunker hunker
now other interesting elements are that
cyborg appears with some upgrades and a
bazooka on his shoulder
since the war started he's clearly had
to round up some xp
points and make sure that he can upgrade
to his best outfit ever
in the leaked storyboards flash was
actually seen carrying his torso which
had been broken in half
so perhaps in getting the joker things
don't go down too well
we can see him standing behind batman at
the end so that all happening at this
moment would be my guess
now we then cut back to the present
timeline and see diana with a torch in
what looks like an underground cavern
this is where she discovers the legend
of darkseid and apparently it comes
towards the end of the movie
after they encounter him through a boom
tube which we'll discuss later in the
video now diana is very much the
historian of the group
so it makes sense that she'd be looking
into it and it's kind of funny that she
has a torch
because she's very old school i have
phones who are lights these days love
i'm just kidding don't kill me now we
then get a close-up shot of her and
behind her can see that there are
actually three mother boxes
which does hammer home that this is
indeed a place that is set up to
chronicle darkseid
it may even be a sort of church in
worship to him as we saw from lex that
there are plenty of people
willing to bow before the master of the
anti-life equation
occur to the aftermath of the invasion
where dark side towers above all
we can actually see his parademons with
their heads bowing down to him
and these are likely the people of earth
who have been transformed into the
monsters
the anti-life equation completely takes
away the free will of all
and it was rumored that darkseid
captured clock and took from him the
kryptonian codex
which allowed him to formulate the way
to control the masses
krypton was of course built on everyone
falling in line and fitting the roles
that they were given at birth
and clark was the first naturally born
child meaning that they could link them
up
though we don't know for definite yet we
then see steppenwolf bowing to his
master
and this happens after the unity you
also see steppenwolf without his armor
well his helmet anyway and it shows his
scaly lizard-like complexion
that looks a bit like mobile well not
nothing
a steppenwolf then attacks the
amazonians as seen in the theatrical cut
but he seems to be far meaner we know
from the behind the scenes looks that he
beheads several of them
and chops up the horses and it's it's
goddamn metal
it's metal we then jump to batflex
saying that he needs warriors whilst
recruiting aquaman
and then diana fails to stop the
detonation at the museum
in the original version she did stop the
kids from being killed
but then another explosion went off
which made her started out herself
bruce had to bring her back around to
realizing that she was a hero
and added far more to her character
which we will be getting here
aquaman then goes to atlantis and this
attack will feature power demons as well
as several atlantean gods
it will also set up more things in the
aquaman solo movie such as the kingdom
being doomed
and then the true king having to step up
which gives arthur more to do
there's definitely a king arthur vibe to
his origins here but for some reason
warner brothers just wanted to cut it
from the original version
we then see the batmobile racing through
the streets and a similar fight to what
happens in gotham harbour
however the footage in cinematography
just looks so much better
and it's almost head scratching that
this wasn't in the theatrical release
we then see steppenwolf fighting arthur
and his eyes glowing blue
perhaps linging him to drawing power
from the boom tube
cut to the hologram of superman which is
being displayed by cyborg
and this was of course shown in earlier
trailers this is what the team used to
decide whether it's possible to
resurrect him or not
and they realize that they can because
of the codex that exists within his
cells
sod of course came back as a horrific
monster yet clark will be different
because
his cells are completely different to
everyone else's on krypton
now an interesting shot is one of ray
fisher aka
victor stone raising his arms this
actually happens in a simulation
after the death of his father and he
sees both him and his mother there
he wants to be human more than anything
but his machine body has made this
impossible
and thus he's getting a lot more
character development in which he
accepts that his father forced him on
this path
we then see barry rescuing iris out of
the crashing car
and if you look closely the guy has no
shoes on
this is because he ran so fast that they
burned off and thus he had to develop
the suit which could handle more
friction
cut to lowest in clark meeting and then
clock taking off
we can see the dirt lifting around him
starting to lift off
showing that he creates his own magnetic
field when he flies
and this of course ties in with the end
of batman v superman and the flying's
seen a man of steel
he's also stood on what might be a
gravestone but
i'm not 100 sure on that so let me know
if you do
below i don't know everything yeah then
there's a a lot of action shots which
include demascara
and the king of atlantis fighting
there's also a bit where cyborg grabs
the unity
and it's at this moment that he sees
darkseid the flash saves him from this
but it scares him to the point that he
realizes how paramount it is that they
stopped steppenwolf
there's a lot of cool action moments in
this montage and looks absolutely
incredible
and oh my god i can't believe they're
making it
next we see frank miller's batmobile
which i want to address later in the
video
though we don't know exactly what part
this happens at it does seem like it's
connecting to the point in which batman
travels to the spy to take down
steppenwolf
i have seen people say that this is
actually the nightmare scene but i'm not
100 convinced due to its seeming prior
to the full invasion
you also know from the storyboards that
there will actually be a five-year time
jump
so i'm not sure if they will show all
the ins and outs between
now after this clip was posted in the
trailer for the trailer
snyder did state that this was actually
in the bat cave and that cavern would
open up and show the flying fox
and this existing is part of his armory
it's even possible that the slimmer and
smaller batmobile fits inside of it
and can eject which is how it's able to
be in the final battle
which we know from the clips of the
finale lastly we see superman appearing
in a frame
and then blasting steppenwolf it also
looks like what could be a boom tube
behind him
and this might be the moment that the
villain is beheaded and then that's
tossed through before being stopped by
darkseid's boot has been said that the
league will actually see him through
this tube
and this could definitely be hinting
towards him appearing at this point
and then diana going off and
investigating him now three of the big
things that i want to talk about in sort
of their own segment
of the frank miller batmobile granny
goodness and the joker reveal that we
did get a first look at earlier in the
week
the first is obviously a massive easter
egg that pulls from the dark knight
returns
and snyder is now officially calling it
the war machine i wouldn't even mind if
we did
another recast on roadie in the mcu and
this was just tony's best mate the
entire time
because damn it looks good snyder has
completely recaptured the look from the
source material
and it makes for a towering machine that
really really shows how much attention
to detail that the creative team are
paying
i'm not sure how much this will feature
in the film as the original justice
league one needs to feature two
however it is possible that it may make
a big appearance
as it's an arsenal on wheels and would
be something that would definitely help
in the war
the second big thing i want to talk
about on its own is granny goodness
unlike the majority of the higher-ups in
apocalypse she actually appears to be
like your normal grandma
who just wants to give you money and
food and maybe
a little little squeeze of the cheek
however she's far darker than that
and will happily cut your head off at
christmas and crap down the hole in your
neck
so that you eat her crap tastes like
joss whedon's justice league you're
having that
now granny goodness started life off as
baby goodness i think i doubt she was a
granny
and she was seen as one of the peasants
of the planet however a dark side picked
her up out of poverty
and trained her to be one of his elite
soldiers a hilarious part in the
training was that she had to raise a dog
and at the end of it she was ordered to
kill it instead she killed the trainer
for ordering her to do that
and it just shows that she is quite a
ruthless person
now she did later turn around and kill a
dog for darkseid
and this showed loyalty to him and him
alone since then she's run orphanages in
search of warriors to join his ranks
and has been integral to the comics
though pretty funny to look at
don't make jokes about her unless you
want that crappy taste of joss whedon's
justice league in your throat
and he's definitely not one to mess with
and lastly i just want to discuss
jared leto's joker though i did an
initial reaction to this first look
i didn't really go into all the ins and
outs of it and i kind of want to touch
upon what snyder said
rather than just giving my personal
opinion this is linkedin with the
nightmare timeline
and though joker wasn't originally part
of it snyder said the following
when discussing the character the joker
is really the only thing that i thought
of in retrospect
but i will say that it was always my
intention to bring joker into that world
and i think with this being the story of
second chances it also makes sense to
bring
leto back as he's a phenomenal actor who
many feel was let down by dc
in suicide squad in the shots leto's
joker wears a bulletproof vest
that's adorned with police badges and
snyder says that these are his trophies
when discussing the scene itself the
director told vanity fair
the cool thing about the scene is that
it's joker talking directly to batman
about batman it's joker analyzing batman
about who he is
and what he is that's the thing i also
felt like fans deserved from the dc
universe
that is to say the giaraletto joker and
the ben affleck batman
they never really got together it seemed
uncool to me that we'd make it all the
way through this incarnation of batman
and joker
without seeing them come together right
now
over me he didn't say that but he did go
on to say the scene explains why bruce
had the joker card taped to his gun that
you see in batman versus superman
i'd always wanted to explore the death
of robin and if there was going to be an
x movie
which of course there probably won't be
i wanted to do a thing where in
flashbacks we learn how robin died
how joker killed him and burned down
wayne manor and that whole thing that
happened between he and bruce
so lots of things there that sound
absolutely amazing
and i would love to see the rumored ben
affleck hbo max batman show
explore not only the death of jason todd
but the destruction of a mana and more
there are really a lot of potential
avenues and i absolutely
love the trailer now obviously i'd love
to hear your thoughts on it so make sure
you comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please drop a thumbs up don't forget
that on the 28th of february we're
giving away three copies of the mcu
phase 3 4k box set to our subscribers
don't don't tell them i like the marvel
universe as well now all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter the links to our socials are in
the description
and you can also support the channel by
clicking the join button and as a thank
you you get videos like this early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
one division
which will be linked on screen right now
we went over the episode top to bottom
and pointed out a lot of the easter eggs
and gave our theories on what's
happening
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more by the way thank
you for sticking through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
and enjoy valentine's day even though
you ruined it with this video
much love